Okay?
We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David p here is a guy who is very upset, I
guess about Virgina.
I genuinely don't even know what they're talking
about.
Take a listen.
This is the type of hate by the way we get
everyday.
Hey parklets, how are you doing for reckless?
You know what?
Your friends, it's free speech TV that will,
uh, you only, he don't even have a hair on
your balls.
You don't have balls either.
Walls of Regina clitoral, you're an idiot.
Liberal.
Oh, I thought there was more.
I think he's, I think he
stays on the phone for awhile.
Like the voicemail is actually still going
okay.
And there he hung up.
All right.
Um, no response needed.
But uh, this is a get out the vote.
Uh, a reminder, you're not going to convince
that guy to vote for a democrat.
You're not going to convince many of these
people to consider something other than Trump.
So once again, just get out the vote.
There's tens of millions of people who didn't
vote last time and who might not vote this
time, who already agree with us.
Just tell them that they should go and vote
because it matters.
Because people like this talking about, you
know, Prick Lis Virginias and balls.
Uh, we're not going to convince them that.
That's a very, very clear on today's bonus
show, we will talk about CNN, Chris Cuomo
in a video threatening a man who called him
Fredo and actually equating the term Fredo
to the n word.
Was it a set up?
CNN is standing behind him.
I have some thoughts.
We will also talk about a company stirring
debate trying to trademark the concept of
Taco Tuesday is taco Tuesday so ubiquitous
that it really should be beyond a intellect,
intellectual property protections, the likes
of which this company is trying to get.
We will discuss that.
We will also talk about really strange things
going on with this entire storm area.
51 event that is being planned and promoted.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show, two ways to get instant access to the
bonus show.
Become a member at www dot [inaudible]
pacman.com or become a patron at patrion.com/david
Ackman show.
I'll speak to you then the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com.